[Applause]
anger on the streets of Haiti's capital
already struggling with a weak economy
these protesters are calling for an end
to high fuel prices and shortages during
violent clashes with demonstrators
police are accused of shooting and
killing a man amid protests in
port-au-prince close by one of his
relatives is overwhelmed with grief days
of protests have left the Caribbean
nation at a standstill roads have been
blocked and some schools banks and
government offices have closed their
doors our conditions are inhumane here
in Haiti the situation cannot continue
fuel suppliers say Haiti's government
owes them about a hundred million
dollars they have refused to make
deliveries until the debt is paid and a
corruption scandal has made things worse
auditors say the government embezzled
about two billion dollars from a fund
linked to a subsidized oil program for
Caribbean nations that money was meant
to improve infrastructure education and
health services president has plundered
the country's economy and become richer
while making us poor we demand that he
step down because if he continues the
system will not change over the past
year corruption scandals have led to
anti-government protests throughout
Haiti where the minimum wage is less
than $3 a day
despite the frustration president moiez
has refused to go earlier this month the
country's newly appointed prime minister
addressed the crisis the government will
focus on enforcing the justice system
and public security reinforcing the laws
of social equality in accelerating
economic growth in order to generate
employment protesters say the crisis is
about more than fuel prices they say the
demonstrations will continue until the
president and his inner circle step down
cod ciello pasado y on al Jazeera